hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
it's been a few days since the last
episode mostly because I got distracted
by five nights at Freddy's 2 but that's
all done with at least for now I ain't
gonna try 20 20 20 20 20 20 20 20 mode
for a good long bit so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna get through this next area
and then I'm gonna try to expeditiously
complete this game because some people
worried that I abandoned it I did not I
just had to try something else for a
little bit because it was frustrating me
but I'm over that now so I'm just gonna
play this and enjoy it good right good I
don't know what to do about the one that
was going to explode on me because
that's just generally bad but they are
giving me some of these electricity ones
which I'm assuming are gonna be able to
stop it quickly quickly quickly now whoa
oh yeah I got two fur okay so they are
giving me the tools I need to be able to
stop those sons of [ __ ] because they
blew me to hell and back
yeah yeah okay disable this run through
run through and through yes okay down
over there needs to go screw you all
right then fine whatever it's all right
it's all good
so look at my hands oh my god I'm doing
some crazy shadow puppet show oh well
I'm done with all of you all right so it
seemed to be doing relatively okay why
was that so hard probably because I was
flustered and as I know flustering
causes me to make mistakes
was there something on the other end of
the hall listen what the hell
Jojo come back oh whoa
Jojo almost died and he left me was a
problem the problems name is sir meets a
lot you again yeah you again we would
think you're gonna mess with me I'm too
good
I'm waiting oh god I can't push past
this meat I can't push this meat very
quickly but I got it probably can Oh
what did he just drop god damn he's
laying out try hey whoa whoa whoa mr.
Bagga nails or whatever the hell that
was no no I got I gotta sign those no no
no no no no no what are you doing okay
that was my face sir sir oh my god I
can't do this oh yeah reloading would be
good idea okay go with that one it's
probably gonna clone himself again oh
good
yeah that's a clone I hope I have some
Healy juice whoa watched ankles
everybody I don't think I do yes I do I
have to good good good exactly way
there we go took care of him let's take
care of this guy whoa gotcha Zippity zap
anybody else want some more oh it's time
to go go time to go go find Tojo run
quickly expeditiously
yes jump in go do it Jojo did oh I
didn't push a button how did I go how
did I go go - Jojo I don't know don't
make the most amount of sense I'm just
gonna assume that everything's
hunky-dory god damn it I gotta go find
Jojo again
oh [ __ ] oh hey watch your language young
man unless you're an old man then it's
solely fine don't tell me I'm going
right back up to cube head he's gonna
pull me out of there and then smash me
in the face with a hammer again cuz I
didn't feel good the first time
joe-joe anybody seen Jojo please tell me
that's a bunch of bullets on the desk
there dad damn it I thought it might
have been bullets Danny
dagnabbit dang so angry cuz what is that
oh that's a thingy yeah gimme gimme
gimme
thank you I almost missed you what I'm
gonna get everything
I forgot how powerful the harpoons were
way after I upgraded them that's why I
did cuz gosh dang dingus
they is powerful so yep I'm just gonna
go with the standard bolts because
they're one do the most damage it took
out the big guy in two hits just two so
haven't gotten lush sniper rifle bullets
in a long time at least I'm full up on
pistol which is another one that I
upgraded fine Kidman whatwhat about Joe
Joe you were just looking for Joe Joe
did you find him uh maybe I should start
looking out for myself
jojo's alternate route obviously led him
into dismay so I need to go ahead I
guess she's alright what's she after
yeah what is she after him did we find
Leslie no we didn't she found Leslie so
that's good
either way Kidman seems to be the only
one that's not affected by it maybe it's
because we all have dark pasts we've all
done horrible things to each other to
ourselves what Redemption could we
possibly have in the face of that
whatever give me that
hey oh happy birthday
anybody else wanna beast anybody want a
piece
I will admit you know even though I get
frustrated by this game it still is a
lot of fun like some of the things are a
little glitchy in here but it's well put
together game in the beginning of the
game and had a lot of environment and
ambiance and it was really really
thoroughly creepy but you know it's a
long game whereas it got to go from
there it's got to go action II so it's a
shame that it does but at the same time
I can understand the game developers the
idea to do that Wow it is pretty in
there oh it's so colorful and playful I
want to go to there you're making
complete sentences now yes that's my job
good good when I get home they'll be
surprised oh I'm gonna go ahead and say
that's not normal I'm sorry stop yeah
Kidman what are you doing you don't
understand you don't know what you'll
become
I do I've seen it you don't understand
what Norvik is after so tell me what is
he after
he's after Leslie what he needs to
finish his science project don't
patronize me
I have orders I can't let him have this
boy
Lesley's the only one who can
[Music]
and Jojo why did you have to go do
goodness well I've been shot bunches at
times smashed in the face of the hammer
Jojo will be fine right her orders from
what is going on here
excess my Jojo only I gets it
Ezra Jojo better be okay Jojo better be
frickin okay I mean having none of this
he didn't come this far why did he run
up and just decide to stand next to
Leslie okay it's just Grayson a guy's
been shot a lot actually why did she
shoot him yeah you better be alive or
I'll kill you
I've grown quite fond of you Jojo not in
that way but at the same time you better
not die my only friend in this damn air
you die I don't know what'll happen to
me I might go out of my mind out of my
mind out of my mind
how dumb oh wow that's fun Jojo you
better be alive all right Joe Joe Joe
Joe Joe Joe Joe
Oh Joe Joe Joe Joe oh I better not be
Joe Joe whoa Joe
oh thank you very much for the warning
it's always good when those prep minds
beat right before they blast me to
oblivion down get down thank you
whoa what was that all right okay
there's a med kit on the wall I'm gonna
grab and then I'm gonna get gone get out
of here
I will forgot what to do I was in such a
[ __ ] hurry cuz everything's going
whew lost and found
okay then another fragment I don't know
how many I've missed so far but I've
been collecting more and more recently
you have a go one yeah Marilla good one
Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
I must find Joe Joe this looks decrepid
okay so there's a same point in there
I'm guessing it wants me to go that way
because is this place blocked off no
I'll pop in here first see what else
might I recan hold what other depressing
thing can happen to me
no from Mira my dearest Sebastian if
you've received this letter then I fear
the worst has come to pass
it means that my investigation got too
close to the truth it means you may
never see me again
I'm sorry I kept it from you but it was
to protect you from either the truth or
my madness I've enclosed a copy of my
files I only hope that you would never
received them but if you do it's up to
you to finish what I started please find
justice for Lily and for me I love you
with all my heart
Mira this is gonna turn out that we were
at the hospital the whole time
everything was already crazy we
already lost all our collective minds
that we just happened to be there I
don't know what's going on and where is
she getting our orders from oh my
goodness well if you say so I was gonna
anyway but first let me open up a key
because I have one of them where lady
y'all right that lady okay I'm gonna
follow you
y'all have a good day now you have a
good day okay
eenie meenie miney moe catch see you I
don't I'm too lazy to go farther back
yay
bullets I need a guy I have plenty of
space I guess okay so now that I have
the bullets oh that's actually starting
to fill up pretty good I'm guessing I'm
piecing together back in my mind might
decrepid mind I wonder what it would
unlock if I got all of them who knows
these things
hi-yah okay oh okay those are some weird
shadows on the wall those just caused by
me are the shadows of my nightmare
living to whatever I'm all right
accuracy all done that's all done sniper
rifle why is that glowing at me I guess
I was just highlighting over there I'm
an idiot okay so I need to be able to do
more stuff those old more shoddy gun
shells
cuz if I ever go up against a boss and
they do load me up I need to actually be
able to hold them I might as well load
up this because I haven't yet and I
don't know why I got that granado's I
don't use enough of them to justify that
I don't have enough for that okay
at this point I'm doing enough damage
it's just about getting enough supplies
not that this is exactly gonna directly
correlate and help what it is what it is
and I am what I am what I am is a sorry
man
trying to get by not me Sebastian not me
not me at all anymore story items that I
need newsstand what do we got office
linked to Foreign Intelligence burned
arrests made building housing community
outreach center burns to the ground
there were allegations the center was
the front for foreign intelligence it
seems interesting okay so why is that
missing
Ivan Diaz freelance journalist never
returned from covering a story his
camera and notebook were found in the
village of Elk River okay then did I
happen to kill him in this nightmare
land or is that just something that
happened I have known who knows who
knows these things
okay bye lady I'm just gonna make one
last pit stop to make sure that no one
else wants to rave at me madly nope okay
bye let's just be on my way back to the
real world where I can solve my real
problems and then I can cry over all my
real losses Oh Jojo
I miss you so much baby no I'm not like
that would you look at that whoa that's
a noise
is there a dude whoa whoa okay who's
would someone's day would be awfully
ruined if I did a little bit of this oh
yeah oh no no I didn't do [ __ ] what the
poop I'm well then just a bunch of bull
didn't I get a bottle or something over
there
for some s also why that got it a
grenade didn't but that did all right
then yay hooray
it really is the 4th of July so why can
I ask why all of this is this thing that
it is hope this doesn't hurt me from
here god damn it
alright might as well get those damn it
there we go okay should be all of them
hopefully what why was this guy alone in
the bathroom shooting off explosive
darts into the walls
we had nothing better to do with this
time I don't know if the green goop was
worth all those bullets I just wasted
whatever sure wish my grenade Technic
would have worked but no Joe Joe Joe Joe
Joe doesn't look like Joe Joe
well I ruined that guy's day
no no no no okay he's down
what house I was surprisingly easy that
guys seemed a lot weaker than I remember
him being sure is nice to have a lot of
bullets it was a nice Apple ah whoa
hey buddy how you doing how's it going
over there
you're doing good doing good buddy ah
you look good you look real good hey you
look good
oh free bolts I'll take one two-for-one
sale whoa ain't good
I'll take these I'm full up I'll have to
shoot some else then
all right hopefully this is far enough
away is I win what do I win Bernie
well no going back now so I don't get my
free one cuz it brought you to shot the
bomb with it but hey I'm not gonna do
that
that's just disgraceful Oh care if I
woulda gotten one right away I this is
just a waste I ain't gonna be made a
solid metal so I would imagine you know
no me no and me I'm gonna shoot that
roofing in the face why are there so
many Rubik clones around black hair
curse the garage is that a play on the
garage
Oh God sniper bullets three of them
about damn time I'm waiting for this
holding out on me all right put that
back there
I'm swimming they want me to snap some
sons of [ __ ] which I'm more than
happy to oblige who wants to be first
yo volunteering how about you back your
hell okay in front of your face is good
to know I heard nothing that was a
mysterious thing that just oh my god it
happened again someone stop this madness
where Rubik go that Rubik oh I hear a
step stomp II hey give me good that's
all a lot of not good wolf - okay
[Music]
running this don't take a break I ain't
good
real big where'd you go hey rub it hey
Rowley hey Ruby Ruby Ruby boy rah this
is bad is a situation I'd rather not be
a part of so I'm just gonna expedite
myself out of this situation run away
also expeditiously you're okay good
thing I got a lot of sprint now that's a
thing that happened
Hey look brain goop I'll just take my
time to get that that's okay hey how
about that oh that's a girl just skirt
by yeah that's good okay that also hurts
I should use something okay I'm on my
way
is there someone behind me is that a
things I need this sorry
needed that okay I'll just stop hitting
the walls and run is that a thing I need
to shoot okay set that off it's anyone
right behind me well that's probably bad
Hey look I got a thing for you that's
it's another present well alright sorry
I just dropped it for me oh you okay
[ __ ] it's hard to run and try to be
clever at the same time Oh papi okay
well I got I got most of them so why
would I need to get all of them little
Sebastian running along hey has anybody
seen my cousin Booker Booker hardly know
her okay
anyway that's all said and done why is
it raining what the hell where did you
get this mood change who's over there
dodo you better be alive Jojo can't
handle this gotta be a way to get up
there I'm leavin Jojo behind I wonder if
you die in this game do you die in real
life okay all right didn't expect the
hug that's okay you can have hug back
why are you naked why is your head also
missing thanks for the bullets all right
how am i doing all of the guns need this
reloaded yeah BAM but they're got plenty
of bolts now stick with a pistol been
doing me good so far took down a Rubik
in one clip who knows what it could do
to a normal normal zom zom nothing else
here okay moving along Oh boys ettus Oh
God
you know I said oh boy kind of regret
that now
I doesn't look fun at all oh do I get to
burn it I get to burn it all yes please
thank you please all right then we got
to the weird slush spider creature so
I'm guessing it's gonna be something
though oh that's convenient Auto healing
walls of douche that's great
made from concentrated stupid what are
you doing I know it's a chain-link fence
but I can't shoot through it man I wish
I could I know you want me to shoot you
but nothing I can do
nothing I could do man nothing I can do
whoa whoa whoa hey hey I was like what
was that thing on the ground that looks
interesting oh yeah I'm dumb that guy is
still raving over there
good keep the party alive man you're the
only one that can do it everyone else
got old and lame oh hey hey okay you
like that
you're a tough one ancient are you gone
you better be gone
you want a rag doll I'm assuming that
means you're actually dead now a lot
about that one over there huh that look
like it hurt
okay I shouldn't waste my sniper bullets
I just love the sniper rifle so much I
can't help myself
so fun anybody else that looks like a
thing that could burst through at any
moment structural weaknesses yeah how
they been here before some of this is
starting to look a little bit familiar
I'm not entirely sure that looks
dangerous and deadly so so what about
that guy straw ash I throw something at
it ah take that technology oh it's fine
damn it's technologies more amazing than
I thought how do you get up
rise and shine there's something
happening why are you all bloody now or
is that the wine hey come here hey your
mother smells like a popsicle
oh no not my mom why are you gonna stick
this mean things whoa no hey come on
it's not so bad come here give me a big
hug I'm sorry we had to fight what am I
supposed to do when I says it
yeah sir sir gentlemen gentlemen
gentlemen please come over this way yes
all right that ended as I expected it
would so I can crawl under it
question mark I'm guessing yes although
the scenes very dangerous maybe he's
just stunned maybe he's not really dead
I mean he is still pulsing right let me
just make sure there's your spine out of
line there I fixed it for you
good job congratula you're a real winner
in life just like me more the fleshy
growth e substance and more of the
electricity doodads I'm wondering what
this facility was originally intended to
be because there's some conflicting
things going oh you oh so that's keeping
the thing in check the organic growth
Rhodey gross very gross all right good
thing I got through there just in time
it would be weird and strange to be
wrapped up in that weird stuff
hey okay so not so much strange and
weird as totally deadness NIST miss like
that scene from Akira towards the end if
you've seen the kuren you know what I'm
talking about you know what I'm tired
about gross journal Sebastian
Castellanos no word from Mira since I
received the packet I'm afraid to take
this evidence to my superiors what
Mira's suggesting is horrifying and may
reach corridors of power beyond my reach
but the evidence she provided is enough
to convince me that Lily's deaths with
not an accident they finally accepted
mirror as a missing person case but
refused to involve me they say it's
because I'm family but I think that they
consider me a suspect the investigation
has stalled but for the sake of my
family I will continue the investigation
on my own so how does that play into
what the hell we're doing here because I
know like either he's doing that on his
own time or off duty or whatever but
here right now there's some [ __ ] going
down and there had to be some [ __ ] going
down because of this whole Hospital
situation I mean I obviously know that
the city isn't really destroyed but that
some people would be a little worried
about all this and I know that Rubik
doesn't really have super powers so like
in the beginning of the game you
remember when Rubik was zipping all
around it's quite obvious that he can't
actually do that hello-oh
missing that's you oh my god whoa
Tatiana she's the nanny nurse at beacon
mental would get your vests out of the
way
disappeared while working late shift no
evidence of her ever loved having left
the building
Oh
oh no no lady come back baby come back
you can blame it all on me oh well thank
good the moon is shifted once again so
why I must ask why why has it shifted
again why does it need to shift why does
there need to be any shifts in this I
thought I was safe inside my own mind
turns out I was lying to myself the
whole time okay
so what else can I upgrade I don't
really know I'm already a steadfast
badass I guess I could do sprint time it
always pays to be able to run just a
little bit more that's why not maybe
maybe maybe there'll be an opportunity
where I won't need to breathe heavily
after running for about ten feet because
that would just be asking for too much
so she go lady Annabelle
Tatiana Guiterrez whatever your name may
or may not have been i'm sure i'm
getting it right and this isn't totally
insulting what is that
hello mental hospital case sealed chief
of staff points finger at former doctor
nurse missing good what's that over in
the center there serbian psycho i
thought i read why a Serbian psycho
according to my knowledge all Serbians
are upstanding
gentlemen and women and awesome people
through and through so congratulations
Serbia for being mark Myers country of
the week
no more bullets can I have any more
bullets before I totally lose my mind
and everyone clicks away from this
stupid video and watch as I turn around
and immediately die hopefully the flow
fleshy growth that closes in on me okay
that same it's not worth it I should
have gotten this before well I got the
goop buddy
oh man yelling over man well I could've
sworn I hate your face but that's okay
you can move it the last minute
I don't mind or anything Sanda I like
you have something to attend to here not
like I'm a busy man thanks for the mag
ammo so go through here yes yes because
there is sniper bullet yes yes I will go
yes yes please thank you all right so
who else wants to be sure I'm running
out of bullets oh yeah up grody it's all
over me at sea my hair what's up there I
can't tell the waters in the way yeah
gady ah so gross
hello how you doing hey guess what
Oh God hey that was my kill come on man
I had him first he was in my sights no
manners no manners fine
looks like someone needs a good ponen to
teach him a lesson or her you never know
with these tentacle monsters it's always
up to oh stop gooping can everything
just stop gooping for like ten seconds
I'm not gonna be here too long oh good
now I can move quickly that must mean it
wants me to run what is that doc grody
thanks now it's giving me a bunch of
Poon's but I haven't had a chance to use
them someone give me something a poon
one is so badly
ah give it to me give it to me good I'm
ready for it
weird blood gun oh okay I didn't mean to
do that
[ __ ] did I do that oh well I should have
done that because that's good god I did
not notice so another one there my bad
didn't notice that
stop can you oh oh if he gets shocked I
get shocked ah that's a problem do
better I have the solution to someone by
me nope hello friend
special delivery okay hi goodbye oh I
need to get him to write in the head
this is a one-shot killing the body
bunch up stop getting up yet dingus
learn to fall over already I just had to
trigger the alarm do
Casta Noah's can't take much more of
this my body
I hope my body's ready okay yeah I know
my body can take it that's from Dragon
Ball Z hope you guys huh I almost didn't
miss that can I have that okay all right
then so hopefully these guys dropped a
bunch of items correct that would be the
good thing to do for me there's a thing
over there there was a way to go over
here but I'm assuming it yeah the goop
okay I need to heal actually a bit cuz I
it was a dum dum and I ran into things I
guess I'll go ahead and use this because
that one takes a little bit of a
breather I can't use that one in combat
I had a lot of health done so that's why
I use the big one also I like using big
hey play with fire while you're
intoxicated with drugs do it burn it
burn it up okay you're done come on cos
smells
you've been over-served burn it up man
so why do I need to use matches when I
have this Lantern here did I not comment
on that before did I not comment on the
ridiculousness of this currents it's way
I'm totally level with it but hey hey
hey
calm down now I'm out of blast range
please tell me yes oh the good thing
that Sasi didn't die from that that
would have been horrible yeah sorry lady
you know I need this I need all of this
I need so many more keys because I need
so many more goodies it's still gooping
everywhere why is it goop why is it got
a goop why is everything got a goo oh
hello what have you got for me special
treat that can't be beat shotgun shells
I'll take it
gotta be more dead bodies right here I
know I shall oh yes filter the green
goop out of the raw sewage it's
definitely gonna still be good to inject
into my brain why not
Oh grody you gross gross man whoa I did
not notice that but I did notice the
disarm button so I'm dumb basically is
what I'm trying to say I'm dumb they're
not yeah whatever whatever whatever
whatever whatever gotta be more careful
gotta be more careful yo markiplier
don't rush your head
you're just being big dumb dumb that's
okay
Tom made my living being dumb
heyy hog not to say all southern people
are dumb it's not what I'm Jessie oh
look a junction box fuse a high-voltage
fuse from a junction box it is still
intact and can be used again okey dokey
so I'm gonna need a so what's all those
sounds there huh what's a what's all the
mass you're making
yeah all right now we're ready to spam
yeah it's so much effort to do this oh
I'm really struggling
oh you mean that anytime I could have
made the sewage go away I was just gonna
use to the smell house good stuff you
know not bad at all of all the raw
sewage sewers that I've ever walked in
this was this was probably the most
pleasant wait no I got to remember the
time when I had a chainsaw wound on my
leg and I walked through raw sewage that
was really good for me that also
explains that all this is just a fever
dream but I'm totally sickened probably
in a hospital about to die why am I
still getting the green goop that's
embedded into the other group is it just
raw green goop and this is where it gets
refined who knows Oh who's moaning huh
Moaning Myrtle oh you oh god eat with
your mouth closed God dang uh what would
be the most tasteful way to finish this
guy off marinade works bye bye bye have
fun with your meal didn't even phase and
those grenades or something whoa okay
then that was a script II do well that
sounds good they're gonna be rolling out
body parts and maybe an ocean of blood
that's gonna flood out no oh you don't
waste a drop do you that's uh that's a
classy lady there I'm gonna assume it's
a lady I have no idea why don't ask me
why
really don't know and you don't want to
know either okay so now what made me
waste a grenade and it made me waste a
shotgun chill so it's already on my bad
list but maybe you can just persuade me
to be nice to it I mean there's got a
lot going for it it's a giant tentacle
monster what's not to love
wait a minute is this about to get
really gross I mean it was already kind
of gross but why why oh yes please
Open Sesame so I'm supposed to trust
this right yo baby here we go I'm coming
baby I'm a-coming
at any moment I could be crushed to
death but I don't care
I was a bit braver than I would have
been good job Castellanos Boston Ellis I
forget what your name is guys down maybe
not for the count
nope apparently there is now he's dead
oh you Sally Suze Oh does anybody care
the answer is no all right that guy
better be down for the count he got up
after missing a head already but he's
probably not Hey Hey You you shut up
okay another one down they're gonna be
varying about let me just make sure you
never know these things okay he was dead
Oh
it's so gross all right I'll sneak by
maybe it won't trigger them or that one
on the ground there that's probably not
dead good uptake I don't know what I get
Scott but it looked like ammo I think I
got a lot of Magnum bullets no I do not
okay that must have been what was that
shotgun shell no maybe was just pistol
ball it's hard to tell
Gus so quickly I'm so lightning fast
can't even keep track of my own motions
yep this was a good choice oh yeah that
was a good refreshing bath I just took I
can't wait to do it again all right so I
need to get through there to do that but
I need to turn off this somehow ah
there's a fuse at the end of the hallway
that's awfully convenient can I burn
that guy that guy's awfully obviously
gonna be burned man if I knew it was the
world-famous Acrobat I wouldn't have
burned you actually I've brought still
one hey you gonna pop down you gonna say
hi to me it's gonna be rude rude rude Oh
fine you know what you get a special
treat you're gonna special surprise face
all right of course of course you didn't
finish him off why would it average or
just bendy life okay thank you very much
at least it softened him up a little bit
really the explosion is like a
tenderizer really breaks down the
protein bonds you know makes it more
gods kill them kill them already all
right thank you thank you thank you for
the juice I'll take this and we'll be on
our way
so now I have two fuses that are
supposedly reusable oh oh oh we're okay
that that happened by the way you stay
down son I like how that shotgun does
like no damage happen whoa okay I'm just
gonna you know what way this is wrong
I'm coming back baby I wouldn't leave
you
I guess I haven't really upgraded the
shotgun mostly because I thought that by
default it would have had a bit more
stopping power but then who knew green
goop could make guns more strong and I
think you're done I think you're done
you're done ain't you yeah you're done
so now I don't know what they'll vis
gonna do but at least the with the
growth of the goop unhindered I'll have
all the stuff to inject into my brain
maybe I should just go to one of those
students to open my pals up oh yes
make my bullets stronger let me run
farther I'll take about no that's a bad
idea okay I thought it was a good idea
before I said it
that again a lot of things seem like a
good idea before they come out of my
mouth well hey no Jacob Neeson a bad was
coming up with names that's why I'd be
fault to Billy so much Billy
Jacob Jeremy hello which one are you
gonna be
No and you're done poking these guys
taking a lot of pistol bullets they're
too tough oh yeah real talk
they're like a half a Rubik okay yep
that could have killed me but good thing
it didn't not too smart for it
oh wait trap me down here Oh No okay it
smells like a trap that looks like a
trap I distinctly see some that kind of
trap like with a mouth and all that huh
I don't know it's just weird you all
right buddy
I played aliens I know what's up what's
up is not your ambush okay go I did it
good for me what did I did all righty
then that's what I get for being Kenai
five nights at Freddy's kicked up my
gaming expertise incredibly I'm now
soaked good games good thing I don't use
all my matches or else I wouldn't been
able to go through here and get all the
secret goodies I'm guessing yeah secret
goodies I'm guessing yeah it is secret
goodies I don't have to guess anymore
okay
so I need to make more agony bolts works
for me that was a lot man I can't
believe I used to have so many agony
bolts just waiting for me everywhere
hi no this is another goop again I
thought it was gonna be another ambush
also why are these things glowing do I
need to shoot them usually when things
are glowing dead space saw me that I
should shoot there and only there all
the time
yeah matches now I can burn anything
else that comes my way
I'm just a pyromaniac in fact I'm
actually very surprised at a this
actually burns why would it just a bunch
of goop wet wet goop see they give me
women - oh come on you're not even
trying to kill me
this guy here is a grade-a am at wha all
right hey I thought I saw someone in
there someone wearing a trench coat ha
they're loading me up with ammo
there's a safe point right here look at
map record so no no I'm not ready not
ready go there isn't even a journal over
here what is this
where's all that wait why is it so it
looks like there might be a journal in
there but I guess not okay
I'll go in it's all about a little bit
hopefully the lady's there again oh she
got to you're taking everybody away from
me I don't like it I don't like it ah
it's all the light hit this is gonna be
the climactic showdown I don't like this
yeah all right oh she is gone I miss her
so dearly what was her name I don't even
remember it's been so long or I didn't
care I don't know I don't even know what
accent this is well that's that's handy
good now I can blind people with my
handsomeness or ugliness you never know
which weapon to use at which time
oh okay gotcha
sorry had to do that I don't know what
else to spend my money on if it's gonna
even qualify as money oh I forgot I
forgot that at a thing huh could add so
much more dabble ajaan that poon oh well
you know what they say a poon wasted is
a pollutant forgot Adam I don't know
what they say don't say anything
actually I actually have to apologize I
am actually headed out the door right
now I have to leave unfortunately this
isn't a full hour but hopefully you guys
still enjoy it nonetheless this has been
a really good time to come back to evil
within I don't know how close I am to
the end of the game but I feel like I
might be getting kind of close just not
quite there yet so thank you all so much
for watching I'll finish this up in the
next episode or another one after that
the next one will be an hour long so
either way thank you again and as always
[Music]
see everything's going crazy other
what I wanted I think we should you know
this is a great start yeah